yeah i do
i love artists who
just own their lane they have blinders
on they're not looking at what i'm doing
and honestly it's tough to be in this
industry and just look forward
and kane does that well and he's
inspiring it's inspiring to watch him
and go
he's where he is because he just
followed his heart and he just chased it
and walker is chasing his dreams too
with the release of his latest album
country style it features his new single
aa which just hit number one at canadian
country radio it's surreal you know i'm
just i'm just a guy from alabama who
started writing songs a long time ago
[Music]
it's pretty funny that it says you know
just trying to write us on the local
country station we'll play because
canada's not local for me but y'all
played it we bet walker's wife is
playing the track too since he pokes fun
at their partnership with this hilarious
life
[Music]
she's too sweet she would she would say
you know that that line's funny but
she's
so far out of my league it's crazy but
we have a special relationship you know
we met in 11th grade so
we have a lot of history and i'm glad we
do i only wish i would have met her
sooner